hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
at the very core of this essay of
Nietzsche's truth and lying and an extra
moral sense lies an insight in you might
say a diagnosis of the human condition
that that we live in that has to do with
these these three themes connected
together rationality abstraction or the
use of schemas schemata and the plural
in Greek and what he calls
anthropomorphism now one of the things
that that Nietzsche tells us is that you
know metaphor is really foundational and
we human beings are you know
metaphorical by our very nature that's
part of what our intellects do and we
can we do this through language and you
know even through the way in which we we
conceptualize on the one end and how we
sense things on the other end that's all
productive right but there and then he
talks about a sort of forgetting of the
fact that that we engaged in metaphors
and there's kind of a consolidating you
know like coins that are just exchanged
back and forth what the the phases have
worn off now
what he's talking about here goes beyond
that because that productive side then
merges and morphs into something that's
in a certainly much more productive
productive at a higher level but also
more restrictive this is where truth is
not just a flash of insight but
something that we can come to rely upon
and rely upon over and over again with
predictability with an exchange ability
this is where the rational is actually
an achievement but it's also for
Nietzsche somewhat stifling as we'll see
so he talks about this shortly after his
famous discussion of what is truth a
mobile army of metaphors Medan M's
anthropomorphisms
a little bit beyond that he says as a
rational being the human being
right forget the metaphorical origins of
things and as a rational being we put
our actions under the rule of
abstractions
he no longer lets himself be carried
away by sudden impressions by intuitions
he first universe Eliza's these
impressions into less colourful cooler
concepts now the fact that they're less
colorful and cooler means that in
certain respects they're more usable
they they don't cost as much to work
with if I can be understood by my
companions very easily because we're
sort of turning the the concepts and the
words that we use into something that is
much less about you know metaphor and
sparkle and you know flash and all that
sort of cool stuff and more into
something that serves a purpose I can
get a lot more done so he says he
hitches the wagon of his life in actions
of them everything that sets man off
from the animal depends on this capacity
to dilute the concrete metaphors to
forget these concrete metaphors and to
dilute them into schemas schemata right
in in plural so he says in the realm of
such schemata something is possible that
might never succeed under the United
first impressions and here's where we
get to something really interesting we
build up an entire world this is only
possible by starting to work with things
as abstractions as schemas yeah you know
as getting away from the real from the
individual from how things are in the
way that we experience them originally
in the way that we talk about them
originally now this happens over the
course of generations not you know just
individual human beings in a state of
nature or anything like that but he says
what are we able to build up a Piermont
a pyramidal order according to camp
and classes we have social distinctions
we can call these people higher and
these people lower beneath them and we
can say this role that role this role
and they're connected in different ways
he says a new world of laws privileges
subordination x' these are relations
human beings bear to each other we also
as you know so many people have pointed
out we also apply this to the rest of
the world we talk about the animal
kingdom great metaphor right there right
and we talk about you know animals
behaving in certain ways and we liken
them to us we make sense of them and the
rest of the world in relation to these
new skin Motta that we're working with
so he says boundary determinations which
now stands opposite the other concrete
world of primary impressions and we
think here's where it gets really
interesting he says that as opposed to
the concrete world of impressions where
we're having our experiences right he
says we see in this other world the
world of abstractions the world of
schemata the world that is revealed to
us by our rational and intellectual
capacities and consolidated in language
as the more solid more universal more
familiar more human and therefore as a
regulatory and imperative world and over
time this comes to take out a greater
strength and after a while that's the
only way that people can really think at
least the the majority of people you
know and and kids think differently but
that we sort of beat that out of them or
we we cajole it out of them or we reward
and punish it out of them we find ways
to stifle that and to get them to fit
into these schemata that we have
developed so he calls us a great
structure of concepts and he says it has
the rigid regularity of a Roman
columbarium has an aura of that severity
and cold this typical of mathematics
you know the very notion that we could
use
mathematics to model the universe nature
here is saying is really a reflection of
what's going on here in the way in which
we have used our intellects and the ways
in which we've developed these codes
these apurate these assemblages of
schema hata so he calls us the residue
of a metaphor and the question we have
to ask that is well what is truth it was
this is about truth and lying in an
extra moral sense
what does truth become and nature says
well there's a couple ways of looking at
it in this in this discussion he says
truth becomes in this dice game of
concepts using each die as designating
counting its spots accurately forming
the correct labels never violating the
caste system and sequence of rank
classifications so truth becomes playing
the game properly following the rules
rules which are you know in the end not
quite arbitrary but certainly
contingently formed they don't reflect
an absolute of the universe or even of
human nature they just reflect having
developed within these schema what else
is truth he goes on and he talks about
truth is something that we find he says
you know if someone hides an object
behind a bush then it seeks and find it
there
that seeking and finding is not very
laudable but that it is that way with
the seeking and finding of truth within
the rational sphere if I define me a
mammal and then after examining a camel
declare see a mammal the truth is
brought to light but nature says it is
of limited value what makes it of
limited value here is where we get to
the anthropomorphism anthropomorphism
means making things after the nature of
the human and Nietzsche is saying here
that what we do very similar to like
what bees do in making their honeycombs
is we shape the universe and of course
ourselves and our societies after
ourselves it's like we're continually
building ourselves out by way of the
schemata by way of concepts that into
these massive grids these massive
organized what can we call them massive
he's got the Roman Columbarium you know
the mighty architecture an infinitely
complicated Cathedral on foundations
that move like flowing water there's a
beautiful metaphor for you right there
what does that we as human beings do
that and we don't do it with wax or
honey or you know things like that we do
it with thoughts and language and we get
people other people to get on board with
this and it's all part of one big
anthropomorphic project he says so he
goes on and he says the investigator
observes the whole world is linked with
with man as the infinitely reflect
fracked an echo of a primeval sound man
as the reproduction and copy of an
archetype man his procedures to hold up
man as measure of all things but we
forget that these things present
themselves to us as pure objects and so
he says we are an architectural genius
we build out from the much more delicate
material of the concepts which we must
fabricate out of our own self this
entire world and that is where we locate
truth so truth is not something that you
could say exceeds the human as a matter
of fact truth is a product of the human
and we consolidate it into these
structures that that undergird and run
through our entire social matrix
you